the mercedes-benz CLS Shooting Brake a
station wagon with Kupe contours or a
coupe a with a station wagon design
that's because in addition to the CLS
who pays for doors the shooting-brake
version also sports a big back hatch and
a lot of cargo space
we'll buy but as our car reviewer Montes
points out station wagon doesn't quite
capture it inside it feels more like a
coupe a and back there's an ample cargo
space but that too is different than in
a station wagon because there's no flat
cargo floor so what is it ultimately
it's a sports car with five seats and a
sizeable hatch
the front end speaks the language of the
CLS coupe a a big Mercedes star embedded
in a brawny looking front grille
daytime running lights in the lower
front apron and 3-way LED headlights
underscore the sporty look
even the indicators on the outside
mirrors make us slick impression along
the side plenty of edges catch the eye
underneath the star a long tailgate
handle emphasizes the backends broadness
the standard LED tail lights already
familiar from the coop a stretched far
into the sides it's certainly a feast
for the eyes our test car standard rear
pneumatic suspension meets the high
standards we expect of this car and
ensures sound handling on the road but
driving this car takes a bit of practice
the gearshift is located on the steering
column for example not the center
console
the Montes says the gearshift on the
right of the steering column takes
getting used to
other cars have the windshield wiper
controls there on the Mercedes that's on
the left side personally I wanted to
turn the wipers on and off there instead
I shifted into neutral or back into
drive but there are advantages here in
the middle where the stick would
normally be there's plenty of storage
space hot money the megaplex fat block
per CD supplies engines ranging up to
386 kilowatts for the Shooting Brake
would that - montes is the 350 CDI he's
now driving as far from a top and engine
but it's fully adequate for a quick
getaway forgot to the font color - I
chose the diesel engine generates 195
kilowatts of power reaches a peg 250
km/h top speed and cost just under 70
thousand euros in Germany plenty of
extras are included
if you like you can equip the CLS
Shooting Brake with all sorts of
electronic gizmos like the adaptive
cruise control called Distronic plus the
practical thing is it'll break to a
standstill for example in a traffic jam
then drive again with just a tap on the
gas pedal and follow the car in front
and brake again nice feature it's
included in the drive assistance package
plus at a price of almost 2700 euros in
Germany
you have to search a bit to find the
seed adjusters in the doors but the
multifunction steering wheel is
self-explanatory classic elegance a
quartz clock in the central console
with the active multi-contour seat back
aged for over 1,500 euros the front
seats offer optimal lateral support it's
not available in the back though
the trunk provides 590 litres of cargo
space
incidentally the term Shooting Brake
parks back to Old English hunting
vehicles that were especially light and
maneuverable one question remains from
antis who's going to buy this car for
someone wanting a station wagon it's
less than ideal because of the loading
sill in the cargo area if you want a
four-door sedan it might feel a bit
tight and those seeking a coupe a might
go for other architectures on the other
hand he likes the look outside and
inside a lot and has get excited about a
car like this if it weren't for the high
sticker price of a guy's done benveniste
what price ever the CLS Shooting Brake
basic model costs just under 62 thousand
euros in Germany